venía por acá para invitarte a votar
habla con tu familia josé cardoso no es
político ni activista es un ciudadano
jubilado residente de esta parroquia del
oeste de la capital que hace lo posible
para convencer a sus vecinos de ir a
votar por la oposición
hay una mesa de diálogo de entendimiento
entre la oposición y el gobierno que se
respete la condición electoral y estoy
creyendo en ese diálogo tras dos años en
el exilio el dirigente opositor tomás
guanipa aspira a ganar una alcaldía en
caracas convenciendo puerta a puerta a
los votantes de que el momento de
recuperar espacios políticos es ahora no
estamos unas elecciones libres aún
tenemos que luchar mucho más por
condiciones libres para que podamos
elegir un nuevo gobierno de lejos luisa
observa a los políticos pasar anhelo un
cambio en 22 años gobernados por el
chavismo nunca le han atendido sus
necesidades la batalla de tanta miseria
y tanta tanta burla el reto que enfrenta
la oposición en las próximas elecciones
regionales será revertir la idea de
abstención que durante los últimos tres
comicios infundió en sus seguidores
entre otras razones por desconfianza en
el consejo nacional electoral el
analista luis vicente león explica que
no fue la mejor estrategia si tú no
cambias estabas condenado
surgir otro grupo opositor y otro líder
a ghost sourcing que se tomará completo
la lucha por el cambio en venezuela
cambiar el discurso no será suficiente
hay quienes como maría angélica los
venció la decepción de una oposición que
no ha logrado ponerse de acuerdo una
estrategia para cambiar de gobierno no
pienso votar porque estoy muy
desilusionada de la oposición después de
una larga jornada josé regresa a su
rutina convencido de que el voto es la
vía especialmente por tratarse de unos
comicios que por primera vez en 15 años
contarán con la presencia de la misión
de observación internacional de la unión
europea